et on accueille en direct notre invité
politique ce matin c'est bruno le maire
bonjour monsieur le ministre merci
beaucoup aux joueurs d'être avec nous ce
matin ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance et on est
ensemble pendant 25 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france bonjour
stéphane bonjourbonjour bruno le maire
on va évidemment revenir sur les
annonces hier soir de jean castex alors
plus de 425 mille cas de co vide ont été
recensés hier dans le pays et jean
castex annonce le même jour un
allègement des mesures des restrictions
sanitaires est ce que vous comprenez
qu'on a un peu de mal à comprendre
je crois que joue ce que tous les
français ont compris c'est que la
vaccination les protéger les choses
allaient évoluer dans la bonne direction
et surtout qu'ils avaient besoin d'un
calendrier je pense que ce dont les
français ont le plus besoin vous moi
tous ceux qui nous écoutent c'est la
visibilité moi je pense à mes amis
restaurateurs ils ont besoin de savoir
quand est ce que les restrictions vont
être levés ceux qui ont un bar ils ont
besoin de savoir quand est ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir à nouveau écrire leurs
clients ceux qui ont une discothèque ils
ont besoin de savoir quand est ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir ouvrir quand vous ouvrez
une discothèque donc à partir de la mi
février vous avez besoin de vous
préparer on va pas leur dire du jour au
lendemain tient demain vous pourrez
ouvrir donc je pense que c'est une bonne
politique de donner un calendrier la
visibilité c'est ce qu'a fait le premier
ministre hier est ce que vous percevez
aussi que les français ont le sentiment
ou l'impression que vous leur annoncer
la sortie d'une copie d'une fin du coc
vide imminente des six trois semaines on
leur annonce que la pandémie peut être
derrière nous d'ici quelques semaines il
faut continuer à se vacciner parce que
ça reste la meilleure protection contre
les formes grade mais que nous espérons
bien que la vie pourra retourner à la
normale vers la mi-février et on attend
tout ça parce que nous sommes tous sans
exception épuisé par cette épidémie on
voit bien l'incidence que ça sur la vie
personnelle sur la vie familiale sur des
enfants évidemment sur la vie économique
donc si nous pouvons tourner la page mi
février ce sera une excellente nouvelle
pour nos taux plein on a tous envie et
très envie d'y croire mais à 80 jours de
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
c'est pas un peu risqué si vous avez un
retournement là la situation sanitaire
juste avant l'élection ça peut c'est
quelque chose qui peut
j'ai aussi nous avons des instruments le
pass vaccinale est là justement pour
nous protéger on a des instruments pour
nous protéger si on devait avoir comme
l'a dit le miz la santé hier nouvelle
forme qui survenait je crois que la
pandémie nous a tous appris l'humilité
elle nous a pris par surprise à de
nombreuses reprises là nous donnons un
calendrier de la visibilité je crois
vraiment que c'est de bonne politique
mais il faut aussi se préparer si
j'avais effectivement le devis y avoir
une nouvelle forme de viol et un
allégement justifié par l'entrée en
vigueur du passé axonale justement c'est
ce qu'a dit hier le premier ministre est
ce que c'est parce que vous sentez que
les français en ont un peu ras-le-bol de
ces restrictions et vous craignez de ne
payer dans les urnes c'était politique
aussi les mesures annoncées hier
là vraiment je vous répondrais beaucoup
de sincérité je crois pas qu'en deux ans
nous ayons pris des mesures dictées par
autre chose que par la santé des
français et la santé des français c'est
la santé physique c'est aussi la santé
mentale ce qui veut dire qu'il faut
trouver le bon équilibre entre les
mesures de restrictions nécessaires et
la liberté qui est indispensable à
chacun j'ai participé à tous les
conseils de défense sanitaire ou presque
à chaque phrase ont eu des débats
étaient des débats sereins des débats
qui posait les problèmes sur la table en
trouvant le bon équilibre jamais aucun
moment je n'ai vu des discussions
politiques on en tient une échéance
électorale ya ceci et cela ça n'est pas
du tout l'obstacle nous prenons souvent
données sur l'économie puisque jean
castex n'a pas répondu à la question est
ce que les aides économiques prendront
fin en même temps que les restrictions
pour les entreprises concernées oui elle
a aussi simplicité les deux français ont
besoin de simplicité
depuis deux ans que nous soutiendrions
les secteurs en difficulté il ya des
mesures de restrictions sanitaires pas
la justice c'est que ceux qui ont des
mesures de restrictions sanitaires ça
peut très bas ils ont plus droit
d'accueillir des consommateurs debout
c'est évidemment et discothèques elles
sont fermées ce événementiel parce que
y'a moins d'événements ça peut être les
salles de théâtre les salles de cinéma
parce qu'on peut plus consommer à
l'intérieur et qu'il ya des jauges dès
qu'ils les restrictions il y a aide des
pouvoirs publics je maintiendrai toutes
les aides sectorielles tant que les
mesures de restrictions sanitaires
seront maintenus pour des raisons à la
fois de protection sanitaire et je le
redis de justice les mesures qui sont
comprises ces deux mesures qui sont
juste ça veut dire que pour être clair
le 2 février plus des pour ceux qui sont
concernés notamment ceux qui
se veut dire que juste veut surtout dire
que jusqu'au 16 février les boîtes de
nuit qui sont fermés continueront à
bénéficier de l'intégralité des aides
les coûts fixes
l'activité partielle
les mesures qui ont été annoncées sur la
masse salariale
et puis des êtres qui vont aussi se
poursuivre sur les prêts garantis par
l'état j'ai annoncé hier la signature
d'un accord de place entre la fédération
bancaire française et les banques pour
permettre aux plus petites entreprises
tpe des pme qui voit arriver des chances
de mars avril et beaucoup d'inquiétude
alors dire si vous avez un problème de
remboursement vous pouvez des galets de
six mois et vous pouvez étaler le
remboursement de prêts garantis par
l'état de 6 ans jusqu'à 10 ans donc vous
voyez qu'on est toujours aux côtés de
ceux qui souffrent le plus de la crise
ou est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
facture économique pour les pour les
dépenses publiques de l'état en fait
combien le coût de cette crise en cumulé
depuis le départ je n'ai pas le chiffre
cumulé tant que la crise n'est pas
totalement terminée tant qu'on n'a pas
fini avec les ailes je vous dire ce qui
compte le plus aujourd'hui ce qui coûte
le plus cher c'est les tests c'est pas
un soutien soyons très clairs c'est pas
le soutien aux restaurateurs au tourisme
à l'événementiel aux boîtes de nuit
c'est des soutiens qui sont parfaitement
légitimes ça se chiffre à 100 ou 120
millions d'euros un peu près uniquement
pour les mesures sur les coûts fixes sur
la lèvre l'activité partielle j'ai pas
encore le chiffre exact mais c'est des
sommes qui restent raisonnables ce qui
coûte le plus cher disons le seul et est
à combien avignon ce matin à peu près
1,5 milliard donc vous voyez que nous
prenons vraiment toutes les mesures pour
protéger les français et pour que
l'accès à la santé à la protection aux
tests soient le plus facile possible
donc nous avons apporté toute la
protection nécessaire aux français
pendant cette crise jean castex a
défendu hier cette politique des tests
est ce que financièrement elle est
encore peu mal cette politique de caste
relatif il/elle la santé comme on dit
n'a pas de prix donc je crois qu'il
était nécessaire pour garantir la
sécurité sanitaire des français
que les tests soient gratuits sous
certaines conditions je le rappelle
ensuite nous espérons tous est ce que le
ministre des finances espère aussi c'est
qu'on puisse sortir de cette crise
sanitaire rapidement on va parler d'un
autre sujet qui inquiète les français en
les unes de la presse régionale se
multiplient ces derniers jours sur ce
sujet c'est la hausse des prix avant de
parler de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie
la hausse des prix dans l'alimentaire ce
matin l'association de consommateurs
familles rurales alerte sur cette hausse
des prix et notamment sur la hausse des
prix des fruits et légumes qui a
augmenté de 9% entre 2019 et 2021 elle
réclame un chèque fruits et légumes
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à le mettre
en place je suis pas favorable à la
multiplication des chèques je l'aï déjà
dit
il y à une interrogation une inquiétude
des français sur leur pouvoir d'achat la
première réponse que nous apportons je
tiens à le redire c'est l'emploi quand
on a un emploi quand on a un salaire on
voit ces questions là avec un peu plus
de sécurité intérieure donc lorsque nous
créons un million d'emplois sur le
quinquennat lorsque nous avons le taux
d'emploi le plus élevé depuis un demi
siècle pour moi c'est la meilleure
réponse à la question du pouvoir d'achat
des français un emploi et un emploi bien
rémunéré là aussi c'est ce que nous
avons fait devant baisser massivement
les impôts baisser l'impôt sur le revenu
pour les ménages les plus modestes ceux
qu'on appelle les premiers déciles nous
avons augmenté la prime d'activité de
100 euros par mois nous avons
défiscalisé les heures supplémentaires
tout ça ça permet à une personne qui est
au niveau du smic puisqu'on parle pourra
d'achat parlons concrètement deux
touchés dont pas 1270 euros net par mois
mais quasiment pas loin de 1500 euros
net par mois c'est ça notre politique du
pouvoir d'achat le travail le travail le
travail et tout ce qui explique que la
solution serait que l'état fasse plus de
chaque qu'il y ait plus de
redistribution pas à vendre distribuer
de la richesse il faut créer de la
richesse et la meilleure richesse pour
les français c'est leur travail leur
emploi et un travail et un emploi bien
rémunéré est-ce que malgré tout alors
vous n'êtes pas favorable à la
multiplication des chèques moscou
prendrait des mesures complémentaires ou
supplémentaires pour aider les français
à faire face à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie on voit que les prix des
carburants atteignent des sommets
inégalés est ce que parce que sks qui a
besoin d'un coup de pouce supplémentaire
en la matière la question clé avait
parfaitement raison de la pause et c'est
l'énergie ce qui explique aujourd'hui
plus de la moitié de l'augmentation des
prix que vivent les français c'est le
gaz l'électricité l'essence voilà enfin
vous avez fait ces trois ses trois pôles
de dépenses mais déjà ça pèse très
lourdement sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français nous nous avons garantit une
protection rapide et efficace ça fait
trois mois que nous anticipons cette ou
ces prix d'énergie trois mois que
j'explique au ministre de l'économie qui
est un reprise économique forte dont
beaucoup de demande d'énergie donc une
augmentation des prix ce que nous avons
décidé je le redis et massif prenait
uniquement les prix l'électricité nous
avons renoncé à la taxe intérieure sur
la consommation finale d'électricité 8
milliards d'euros de recettes en moins
pour l'état 8 milliards d'euros de
pertes fiscales pour l'état pour
protéger les français deuxième décision
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre nous
avons relevé le plafond de l'énergie à
prix bas l'énergie nucléaire à prix bas
pour que les français puissent en
bénéficier quand j les français les
ménages et les entreprises je rappelle
que dans l'opposition personne n'a porté
de solution à ce problème et si au 1er
février il n'y a pas une augmentation de
45 % de la facture d'électricité ni des
ménages ni les très petites entreprises
du boulanger du coiffeur du restaurateur
c'est parce que seuls nous avons eu le
courage de prendre cette décision
j'entends l'âme pécresse qui nous dit ah
ben je serai pas quoi faire j'ai pas la
solution
j'entends madame le pen qui nous dit il
faut baisser la tva je rappelle que les
petites entreprises ne payent pas la tva
sur l'électricité dont elle n'aurait pas
été protégés contre cette augmentation
des prix nous nous avons pris des
décisions massive radical qui fait qu'au
1er février les français ne verront pas
la facture d'électricité augmenter de
plus de quatre prévenus dit on va y
revenir sur les prêts directs restent
évidemment est ce que vous nous dites
sait capable de nouvelles mesures sur la
table alors non je dis pas ça je dis que
je suis devenu après le dernier sujet le
dernier sujet tout à fait le dernier
sujet qui reste c'est les prix de
l'essence c'est sûr que quand vous avez
le litre de diesel qui dépasse les 1
euro 60 moi je suis élu d'un territoire
rural dans leur jeu voit bien à quel
point mes administrés lorsqu'ils
prennent leur véhicule c'est pas par
choix et c'est pas dix bornes qu'ils
font dans la journée ça peut être 90 100
120 150 donc ça coûte cher il ya une
première réponse l'indemnité inflation
100 euros elle couvre déjà une partie de
cette augmentation a été fait pour cela
pour je le rappelle 38 millions de
français là encore les oppositions ne
proposait pas quelque chose d'aussi
généreux et de si efficace est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin moi je travaille
sur ce sujet on va y travailler aussi
pendant le week-end avec mes équipes on
va voir s'il ya des solutions
supplémentaires qui sont nécessaires qui
sont possibles pour évaluer au calme les
pistes envisagées pour l'instant je veux
pas mettre de deux pistes sur la table
je dis simplement que je ne reste pas
les bras croisés en écoute et empilés
près décent sont débrouillés vous
évidemment que non les prochains jours
nous regardons ce qui est possible une
fois encore je ne ferme la porte à
aucune solution je juge garantir que ce
soit efficace que ce soit pas excessif
pour les finances publiques et que ça
aide surtout ceux qui n'ont pas d'autre
choix c'est à dire ceux qui travaillent
qui n'ont pas d'autre choix pour aller
travailler que de prendre leur voiture
et de remplir leur voiture avec du
carburant est ce que vous craignez la
colère de ces français est ce qu'un elle
risque de retour des jeunes
c'est pas comme ça que nous prenons nos
décisions propres ministre et que le
présent la république nous voyons un
problème stratégique qui est
l'augmentation de prix d'énergie nous
apportons une réponse immédiate le
bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz le gel des
prix sur l'électricité pas plus de 4% et
nous regardons aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe sur les carburants et nous
apportons aussi une réponse de long
terme elle tient en un seul mot
indépendance énergétique et vous nous
l'avez dit bruno le maire ces mesures
elles sont prises pour les particuliers
pour les entreprises mais qu en est il
des collectivités certaines communes
aujourd'hui alerte sur les difficultés
qu'elles ont à faire face à cette
augmentation des prix de l'énergie est
ce que les collectivités sont oubliés
par le gouvernement dont elles ne sont
pas oubliés des collectivités ont
bénéficié aussi des décisions que nous
avons prises sur l'augmentation de la
reine du volume de tarifs réduits de
l'électricité nucléaire
les associations vont en bénéficier
aussi c'est pour ça que je défends le
coton de vigueur cette décision je vois
bien qu'elle est attaquée par les
oppositions j'étais au sénat ya deux
jours j'ai été attaqué par la président
de la commission des affaires
économiques jeu juste se rappeler que
cette augmentation du volume de
l'électricité réduits c'était une
proposition de françois fillon en 2009
parce que tous les gens raisonnables
tous les gens responsables et dieu sait
que beaucoup de responsables politiques
aujourd'hui ne regarde pas les choses
avec suffisamment de l'ue
seule solution efficace pour empêcher la
flambée des prix d'électricité c'est
l'augmentation du volume d'électricité
nucléaire a priori une dernière question
sur les collectivités puisque
l'association des petites villes vous a
écrit elle vous demande la mise en place
d'une dotation énergie vont
nous avons pris et voyez si je vous
écoute depuis début de l'émission c'est
intéressant ou pas livré une dotation il
faudrait un chèque il faudrait très bien
nous nous avons bien sûr mais je dis
simplement que six ministres des
finances à chaque fois qu'on demandait
une dotation un chèque répondez oui à la
france aujourd'hui serait ruinée et
trésor public européen euro dedans nous
avons nous une politique qui est
responsable nous prenons le sujet
stratégique l'énergie nous apportons une
réponse qui est une réponse efficace et
rapide mais qui passe par la
participation de touche l'état mais
aussi edf
edf sur la vous vous disiez que les
oppositions critiquer la mesure que vous
venez d'évoquer sur la fourniture
d'électricité nucléaire à prix réduits
vous demander à edf de passer d'une de
santé rawat 100 à 120 il n'ya pas qu'il
n'ya pas que les oppositions qui qui
s'inquiètent de cette décision ils iront
à jean bernard lévy le patron d'edf qui
s'est exprimé sur le sujet en disant
qu'en fait vous faisiez un cadeau ses
concurrents
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous inspire son sa réaction je
rappelle que l'état est actionnaire
ultra majoritaire de f 84 points
quasiment quatre garçons l'état et c'est
surprenant actionnaire majoritaire donc
je pense que c'est légitime que nous
demandions à edf un effort quand on
estime que c'est l'intérêt général qui
est en jeu savez quand on prend une
décision comme ça ça fait deux mois que
je travaille jour et nuit c'était un
travail intense on pèse le pour on voit
bien le contre bien sûr que c'est un
effort que nous demandons à edf mais
imaginez ce que cela aurait été en
france si le 1er février des dizaines de
milliers de petits entrepreneurs ont des
factures d'électricité très élevés parce
qu'ils sont restaurateurs parce qu'ils
sont boulangers parce qu'ils sont
coiffeur parce qu'ils travaillent dans
la métallurgie avait vu une augmentation
de 45% leurs factures c'était des
dizaines de billets de faillite je pense
que ça aurait été insupportable
socialement et économiquement imaginez
les ménages modestes qui ouvrent leurs
factures qu'ils s'aperçoivent que la
facture moyenne c'est à peu près 900
euros 1000 euros finalement c'est pas
mille euros qui doivent payer c'est 1450
mais vous imaginez la réaction sera
animée le gouvernement vous faites quoi
céderait était insupportable donc nous
avons demandé un effort à edf nous
serons toujours aux côtés d'edf quand
les prix étaient très bas il ya une
dizaine d'années et qu'il fallait
recapitaliser edf renoncé un dividende
de l'état nous avons pris des décisions
pour protéger edf aujourd'hui les prix
sont plus haut nous demandons un effort
edf il me semble que c'est une question
de justice et de protection des français
si jamais devait y avoir la moindre
difficulté pour edf
l'etat sera toujours aux côtés d'edf
c'est un fleuron national c'est une
fierté c'est un des éléments de la
puissance économique française
absolument décisif donc nous serons
toujours aux côtés des salariés
d'edf mais de toutes les manières qu'ont
été employée par le passé et de toutes
les manières que nous avons envisagée
pour le futur je rappelle que quand on a
parlé du projet des reculs nous étions
prêts à nationaliser la partie nucléaire
d'edf donc deux sommes de toute façon
quand je dis nous c'est l'état c'est à
dire les français c'est à dire des
sociétés la société française aux côtés
d'edf faut recapitaliser
nous verrons quelles seront les
décisions nécessaires je dis simplement
qu a pas d'inquiétude à voie et qu'il
faut pas créer dans ces moments poli qui
sont comme tous les membres politique un
peu intense d'inquiétude inutile les
salariés d'edf n'ont aucune inquiétude à
avoir nous allons investir dans de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires nous
allons ouvrir des perspectives de
développement massive à edf sur le
nucléaire edf s'est engagé sur les
énergies renouvelables est là aussi les
perspectives de développement qui sont
formidables elle a des talents elle a
des compétences elle a un savoir faire
et elle a le soutien total et absolu à
tout instant de l'état donc cette
entreprise est une grande entreprise
publique française n'a aucune inquiétude
à se faire et on va parler du nucléaire
mais juste un mot puisque edf assure que
la mesure de limitation à quatre pour
cent de la hausse des prix entraîne un
manque à gagner de 8 milliards pour
l'entreprise ont confirmé sophie non je
peux enfin ça dépend comment le calcul
c'est une perte de chance on pourrait
dire ce que dira que des f aurait pu
gagner beaucoup d'argent parce que les
prix sont très élevés et on lui demande
aussi de renoncer à une part de cet
argent pour le rendre aux français mais
ce que c'est pas la définition d'un
service public est ce que c'est parce un
service public renoncé à gagner beaucoup
d'argent sur le marché pour que les
consommateurs français et les
entreprises françaises puissent en
bénéficier si on ne veut pas que des f&a
ça et dans ce cas là ne parlons plus de
service public de l'énergie ne parlons
plus de capital détenus par l'état et
privatiser edf allons au bout de la
logique et de la cohérence si vraiment
on estime qu edf dès que les prix sont
très haut doit en profiter faire des
profits considérables et ne pas protéger
des français dans ce cas la privatiser
edf c'est pas ma vision d'un grand
service public de l'énergie
je tiens la participation de l'état à la
participation très majoritaire et donc à
l'apache la possibilité que l'état
lorsqu'il voit que les français sont
touchés dans leur coeur dans leur vie
quotidienne par l'augmentation des prix
soit protégé par l'état est protégé par
edf on comprend vos arguments enfin edf
est quand même pas dans une forme
olympienne entreprises a été obligé de
porter massivement l'électricité au mois
de novembre par exemple y aller vous
avez évoqué les défis colossaux auquel
elle à faire face notamment sur les
nouveaux opère quand on voit le les
difficultés de flamanville par exemple
on se demande si un le l'entreprise et
est calibré pour faire face et si tout
ça est bien raisonnable il y ait deux
chaux debry avait quelque chose a épousé
sur les fournisseurs qu'à travers or
tente je peux vous dire que nous
veillerons au grain et que nous
assurerons que les fournisseurs
répercute bien l'intégralité de la
baisse des prix sur le consommateur
final et croyez moi je ne suis pas prêt
à laisser passer les abus sur ce sujet
on a demandé à la commission de
régulation de l'énergie de surveiller et
je vais là personnellement ce que la
répercussion de la baisse des prix soit
intégrale et que au passage les
fournisseurs ne sont même pas plein les
poches est ce que nous avons fait ça
nous en aller simple de df pour mais je
peux comprendre cette crainte nous avons
fait ça avec le président la république
et jean castex pour les français pour
protéger les français et certainement
pas pour les fournisseurs donc nous
veillerons au grain lorsque nous prenons
décision comme celle-là nous devons nous
assurer qu effectivement ça et bien aux
ménages français et aux entreprises
françaises sur le sujet nucléaire là
aussi mettons cartes sur table la
réalité c'est qu'on a tellement hésité
au cours des décennies pour savoir si
oui ou non ont continué dans le
nucléaire est une veillée eu
d'avertissement carte de compétence le
drame c'est la perte de compétences sur
la fabrication des réacteurs nucléaires
et qui a fait qu'il ya eu certains
défauts et certaines difficultés j'ai
été louise économique a demandé un audit
de la filière nucléaire à jean martin
folz précisément parce que j'ai
découvert en arrivant dans mon post
qu'il y avait eu une perte de
compétences une perte de savoir faire
qui n'est pas du tout la faute des
salariés d'edf mais qui résulte des
hésitations qu'il y a eu en france
depuis dix ou vingt ans sur la
réalisation de nouveaux réacteurs
maintenant que le cap est fixé que le
président de la république annoncé la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs et un
engagement total sur la filière
nucléaire avec de la recherche sur des
petits réacteur modulaire avec de la
recherche fondamentale sur le nucléaire
va tout ça nous permet d'envisager
l'avenir avec plus de sérénité et de
retrouver les compétences ont été perdus
mais quand je prends juste l'exemple de
flamanville où d'autres rect c'est la
soudure à chaque fois qu'il pose une
difficulté un soudeur nucléaire c'est 50
formations c'est une technicité
incroyable
formation vous savoir qu'il y aura 15
ans ou 20 ans de chantier devant vous qu
envoyer la facture de flamanville bruno
le maire à ce que c'est économiquement
raisonnable de se lancer dans la
construction de nouveaux repères moi je
vois surtout la facture d'électricité
je vois quelqu'un feuilletons et tricité
fait pas de nucléaire et bien je vois
pas très bien comment est-ce qu'on va
alimenter les consommateurs alimenter
nos voitures électriques
réindustrialiser le pays est décarbonée
d'autres industries à moi sur une autre
actualité puisque alstom annonce ce
matin 7500 recrutements nets dans le
monde en 2022 est ce que parmi ces
regroupements et on aura en france oui
on aura en france près de mille en
france ça prouve une seule chose c'est
que nous sommes en train de réussir la
réindustrialisation de la france c'est
début et je reste prudent mais nous
sommes dans la bonne direction nous
réindustrialiser la france nous créons
des emplois industriels et regarder les
annonces qui ont été faites par les
grands groupes étrangers dix mille
emplois nouveaux qui va être créée en
france grâce à l'attractivité retrouvée
de la france donc la reconquête
industrielle qu'a longtemps été une
grande chine est avec des déclarations
et pas de décision ou c'est des
décisions des choix fiscaux favorisant
la compétitivité des entreprises avec
notamment la baisse des impôts de
production de la formation la
valorisation de grandes filières
industrielles comme le nucléaire et des
résultats concrets en termes d'emploi et
en termes d'ouverture de sites
industriels alors il ya des résultats
mais là aussi il ya aussi des sujets qui
posent problème en matière de nature
d'industrialisation au maintien en
activité et je pense à la société
aveyronnaise de méthodes de métallurgie
à samedan l'aveyron qui dont les
salariés sont en grève occupent le site
depuis 57 jours l'entreprise avait été
rachetée par un groupe chinois en 2017
elle a été placée en redressement
judiciaire en 2009 elle est en cessation
d'activité depuis la fin de l'année
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire vous les
avez vous êtes intervenu dans ce dossier
et se disent que le compte n'y est pas
quel est qu'elle est de quel est votre
moi ce que je redis aux salariés que
j'ai reçus aux pages et ressort
syndicats à bercy je suis un homme de
parole où je tiens mes engagements quand
j'ai dit à quelques années au sahara et
d'ascq ovale dans le nord votre aciéries
ne fermera pas elle n'a pas fermé et là
j'ai dit aux salariés à sam que nous
allions réindustrialiser le site de
kasubi et là il ya des vraies
perspectives nota monde dans leur
traitement des batteries électriques là
je crois qu'il ya des perspectives de
réindustrialisation qui sont très
intéressantes pour le bassin de
decazeville c'est la première fois est
ce que j'ai fait nous le tiendrons j'ai
fait une deuxième promesse qu'il y ait
un accompagnement de chaque salarié es
et que renault fera le nécessaire j'ai
reçu le président et le directeur
général du cas des mets aux qui ont pris
les engagements dans mon bureau sur
l'accompagnement y compris
l'accompagnement financier des salariés
deuxième promesse tenue et puis il ya
une troisième promesses c'est la plus
difficile et je leur ai pas caché là
aussi je leur ai des choses avec
sincérité c'est trouver un repreneur
pour le site industriel de l'assam à
c'est plus difficile il y a des
perspectives appelé hier la présidente
de la région carole delga pour en parler
avec elle c'est les pistes qui restent
encore très préliminaires dont je ne
veux pas créer de faux espoirs
il ya une piste qui commence à se
dégager l une fois encore très
préliminaires nous sommes prêts à la
soutenir il y en aura peut-être d'autres
mais je tiendrai aussi cette 3e
promesses et sur cette troisième
promesses sur la reconversion du site
tient un doute de la part des gens dans
sa main oui c'est là dessus qu'il ya un
doute et j'ai très franc avec vous si
j'avais une solution tout jamais n'ayez
pas d'inquiétude comme je le disais sur
edf là ça n'est pas le cas je ne peux
pas vous dire avec certitude que nous
avons un repreneur industriel
aujourd'hui c'est juste que j'ai fait
une promesse et je ferai tout pour la
tenir
oui à autre sujet en ce début d'année
sur la situation économique du pays
le
déficit le déficit commercial de la
france qui atteint qui atteint des
records au mois de mai au mois de
novembre avec une lune année une année
terrible est-ce que ça c'est pas un
indicateur qui qui vous posent question
qui vous pose problème pour l'avenir on
est en situation de reprise il n'empêche
que sur ceux sur ce point précis on est
on est on accumulé des retards ici quand
une grande faiblesse pour le pays vous
avez parfaitement raison et les
indicateurs aujourd'hui économiques qui
sont très positifs
l'emploi indicateur orienté à la hausse
les investissements indicateurs orienté
à la hausse la croissance nous allons
être l'un des grands pays de la zone
euro qui fera la croissance la plus
forte en 2021 avec l'inflation la plus
faible c'est ça la réalité de la
situation économique française un des
grands pays de la zone euro qu'à la
croissance la plus forte avec
l'inflation la plus faible et donc les
résultats économiques de la france grâce
aux salariés grâce aux entrepreneurs
sont tout simplement exceptionnelles
billes un point rouge le point rouge
c'est de déficit commercial pourquoi
parce qu'on apporte beaucoup d'énergie
beaucoup de produits étrangers et que
notre capacité d'exportation de nos
propres produits notamment parce qu'il
ya une désindustrialisation massive est
insuffisante moi j'en fais l'objectif
stratégique de l'économie française à 10
ans ce qu'il faudra dix ans pour
retrouver un solde commercial qui soit
positif mais je vois pas pourquoi
jusqu'aux années 2000 on avait un solde
commercial positif est qu'on se résigne
ray avoir effectivement une balance
commerciale négative c'est à dire
importer plus de produits et payer plus
de produits produits à l'étranger que
nous n'en exportons obtenant produisons
en france donc j'en fais effectivement
l'objectif stratégique de l'économie
française à 10 ans question bruno le
maire
quel regard vous avez porté sur ce qu'il
s'est passé à mercredi matin au
parlement européen lors du discours d'
emmanuel macron le chef de l'état a
répondu aux questions des députés
français vont perdre des euro députés
français dans ce qui ressemblait plus à
un débat de campagne présidentielle
je pense que la france ne sort jamais
grandi quand les oppositions utilise une
tribune européenne pour livrer des
débats de politique intérieure nationale
sur la scène européenne
il y a des débords opère question des
frontières la question de l'immigration
illégale la question de la
réindustrialisation
de l'autonomie technologique face à la
chine ou face aux états unis de la
meilleur moyen de parvenir à nos
objectifs de décarbonation de l'économie
moi je regrette qu'on se serve d'une
tribune européenne pour se livrer à des
jeux politiciens c'est ce qu'ont fait
les oppositions face au président de la
république je ne suis pas sûr que cela
qu'on dise la france mais ce que du coup
ce n'est pas facilitée par le fait que
cette présidence un ton en pleine
campagne présidentielle
on était décalés comme je crois
profondément à la lucidité des français
je pense que lorsqu'il voit un débat au
parlement européen ce qu'ils attendent
le responsable politique quelle que soit
leur affiliation politique
c'est qu'ils parlent d'europe et du
projet européen et que tous ceux qui
parlent de l'europe du projet européen
au parlement européen en sorte grandi
aux yeux des français merci beaucoup
merci merci d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]